In 2000, I told graduates to not be afraid to fail and I still believe that.
But today, I tell you that whether you fear it or not, disappointment will come.
The beauty is that through disappointment, you can gain clarity...
...and with clarity, comes conviction and true originality.
Many of you here today are getting a diploma at this Ivy league school...
...because you have committed yourself to a dream and worked hard to achieve it.
And there is no greater cliche in a commencement address than "follow your dream".
Well, I'm here to tell you that whatever you think your dream is now, it will probably change.
And that's okay.
Four years ago, many of you had specific vision...
...of what your college experience was gonna be and who you were gonna become.
And I bet today most of you would admit that your time here was very different...
...from what you imagined.
Your roommates changed, your major changed.
For some of you, your sexual orientation changed.
I bet some of you have changed your sexual orientation since I began this speech.
I know I have.
But through the good and especially the bad,...
...the person you are now is someone you could never have conjured in the fall of 2007.
I've told you many things today, most of it foolish but some of it true.
I'd like to end my address by breaking a taboo...
...and quoting myself from seventeen months ago.
At the end of my final program with NBC, just before signing off, I said,...
..."Work hard, be kind, and amazing things will happen."
Today, receiving this honor and speaking to the Dartmouth class of 2011...
...from behind a tree trunk, I have never believed that more.
Thank you very much and congratulations!